I know you you're your guy that likes to
enjoy your downtime you do anything fun
this this winter you get out you play
sports what do you doing I am kind of an
outdoors guy I have to go outdoors every
day pretty much but I've been seeing we
just got back you're in skiing yeah we
just got back from a little ski trip
which is a lot of fun and I hadn't been
skiing in a couple years cuz it just
seems like a lot of work but it all kind
of came back to me you know remember
when you ever goes you ski right ya know
the first time you went skiing how
difficult that seemed I didn't know
anything about you know like the way
they labeled trails for difficulty like
the black diamonds for difficult it was
blue yeah greens and I was in Colorado
and I pull in this convenience store and
I said to the guy behind the counter so
what's the best mountain to go skiing at
around here and he looked at me right in
the eyes and he said you know what I
like Copper Mountain but a lot of people
don't like to go there because they're
afraid of all the blacks racist
and then he said but you know what I
don't mind the blacks he said I have a
lot of fun with him but they will beat
you up they will be through and he said
they are all over the mountain
everywhere
and guess what some of them not very
well-groomed but he said if you want the
good white powder that's where you gotta
go I thought well I am NOT going to cop
them out you just have to be so
politically correct nowadays yeah I was
just in Nashville and I had this cab
driver pick me up from the airport nice
guy a black african-american gentleman
and he said his name was Boyd and I said
I'm sorry what was your name I want to
make sure I heard him right yeah he said
Boyd Oh Boyd
I have never pronounced Adi so hard boy
nice city you got here Boyd Boyd uh but
somebody told me that I don't enunciate
some of my words when I speak like God
they said when I say huge I don't
pronounce the H I just go huge instead
of huge you know and that annoyed this
person and I thought that's kind of a
silly thing to be annoyed about you know
I could see like if I didn't pronounce
my H is when I laughed that could be
annoying but you know what I'm saying I
know what you're saying